ласкаво просимо назад до курсу «Розуміння квантової інформації та обчислень», мене звуть Джон Вотас, я технічний директор з освіти в IBM
Quantum. Це 14-й урок серії і другий урок четвертого розділу, присвяченого квантовому виправленню
помилок. На попередньому уроці ми вперше розглянули квантове виправлення помилок, включно з дев'ятиqubit-овим кодом Шора, який встановлює, що
квантове виправлення помилок є можливим у теорії. Ми також обговорили дискретизацію помилок, яка дозволяє нам
виправляти довільні квантові помилки на qubit-ах, фактично проєктуючи їх на бітові перевертання та фазові
перевертання. На цьому уроці ми розглянемо формалізм стабілізаторів — математичний інструмент, за допомогою якого ми можемо
задавати й аналізувати широкий клас квантових кодів виправлення помилок, відомих як стабілізаторні коди. Сюди входить 9-qubit-овий код Шора
разом із багатьма іншими прикладами, включно з кодами, які, мабуть, набагато краще підходять для реальних квантових
обчислювальних пристроїв, ніж код Шора. Не кожен квантовий код виправлення помилок є стабілізаторним кодом, але багато є такими,
включно з кожним прикладом, який ми розглянемо в цій серії. Безумовно, існують цікаві та потенційно корисні квантові коди виправлення
помилок, які не є стабілізаторними кодами, але вони, як правило, значно складніші, і в будь-якому разі немає
сумнівів, що формалізм стабілізаторів є наріжним каменем у фундаменті квантового виправлення помилок, і ми будемо
активно спиратися на нього протягом решти розділу. Ось короткий огляд уроку: ми почнемо з короткого обговорення
матриць Паулі та тензорних добутків матриць Паулі, які можуть представляти як операції на qubit-ах, так і
вимірювання qubit-ів, як я поясню. У цьому контексті ми часто називаємо їх спостережуваними. Потім ми повернемося і
ще раз розглянемо код повторення і побачимо, як ми можемо описати його через операції Паулі та спостережувані, що одночасно інформуватиме
та перейде в загальне обговорення стабілізаторних кодів, включно з кількома прикладами, основними властивостями стабілізаторних
кодів і тим, як ми можемо виконувати фундаментальні завдання кодування, виявлення помилок та їх виправлення.
Ми почнемо урок з короткого обговорення операцій Паулі — головним чином, щоб підготувати підґрунтя для
формалізму стабілізаторів, але також щоб зазначити кілька ключових фактів і встановити базову термінологію. Спочатку ось матриці Паулі:
включно з одиничною матрицею 2×2, а також трьома неодиничними матрицями Паулі, які ми позначатимемо
великими літерами X, Y і Z протягом решти серії. Усі чотири матриці є як унітарними, так і ермітовими, і ми можемо
ототожнювати їх з операціями на qubit-і, включно з операціями, які ми можемо навмисно виконувати, а також помилками, як ми
обговорили на попередньому уроці. Неодиничні матриці Паулі X, Y і Z антикомутують одна з одною,
тобто XY дорівнює -1 × YX, XZ дорівнює мінус ZX, а YZ дорівнює
мінус ZY, і ти легко можеш перевірити ці співвідношення, виконавши множення. Ці співвідношення антикомутації
дуже прості, але вони надзвичайно важливі у формалізмі стабілізаторів та в інших місцях, і зокрема
ми побачимо, що ці мінус-знаки, які виникають, коли ми міняємо порядок двох різних неодиничних матриць Паулі в добутку, точно відповідають
виявленню помилок у формалізмі стабілізаторів. У нас також є правила множення, перелічені тут: кожна
матриця Паулі є власним оберненим елементом, що узгоджується з тим фактом, що вони є і унітарними, і ермітовими. Якщо ти перемножиш будь-які дві різні неодиничні
матриці Паулі, ти завжди отримаєш плюс або мінус i, помножене на третю неодиничну
матрицю Паулі. Зокрема, з точністю до глобальної фази Y еквівалентна X × Z, що пояснює наш акцент на помилках X і Z у
квантовому виправленні помилок. X представляє бітове перевертання, Z представляє фазове перевертання, і тому з точністю до глобальної фази Y представляє
обидві ці помилки, що відбуваються на одному qubit-і. Ці чотири матриці всі представляють
операції, помилки або відсутність помилки на одному qubit-і, але часто зручно об'єднувати їх у тензорний добуток,
щоб виконувати операції або помилки на кількох qubit-ах. Як термінологічне зауваження: коли ми говоримо про N-qubit-ову операцію Паулі,
ми маємо на увазі тензорний добуток будь-яких N матриць Паулі, як у наведених прикладах.
Також зазвичай вживають термін «операція Паулі», коли присутня глобальна фаза, але щоб усе було якомога простіше,
я буду використовувати термін «операція Паулі» для позначення просто тензорного добутку матриць Паулі. Вага N-qubit-ової операції Паулі —
це просто кількість неодиничних матриць Паулі в тензорному добутку. Наприклад, N-кратний тензорний
добуток одиничної матриці 2×2 сам з собою є операцією Паулі ваги нуль. Тензорний добуток двох матриць Паулі X
та купи одиничних матриць має вагу два і так далі. Інтуїтивно кажучи, вага N-qubit-ової
операції Паулі — це кількість qubit-ів, на яких вона діє нетривіально, і типово квантові коди виправлення помилок
розроблені так, щоб вони могли виявляти й виправляти помилки, представлені операціями Паулі до певної ваги. Ми можемо
розглядати операції Паулі різними способами, зокрема як операції, що навмисно виконуються квантовими gate-ами,
а також як помилки, і незабаром ми також побачимо, що операції Паулі можуть описувати вимірювання. Іноді також корисно
думати про операції Паулі як про генератори певних множин у алгебраїчному сенсі, який ти можеш впізнати,
якщо знайомий з теорією груп. Якщо ти не знайомий з теорією груп — нічого страшного, це справді не є обов'язковим
для цього уроку, але якщо тебе цікавить вивчення квантового виправлення помилок більш поглиблено, ти можеш виявити, що певна
базова теорія груп дуже корисна для цього. Як би там не було, припустимо, що P1 через PR — це N-qubit-ові операції Паулі,
тобто P1 — це N-qubit-ова операція Паулі, P2 — це N-qubit-ова операція Паулі і так далі. Коли ми говоримо про множину, породжену
P1 через PR, ми маємо на увазі множину всіх матриць, які ми можемо отримати, перемножуючи ці матриці між собою
у будь-якій комбінації та в будь-якому порядку, беручи кожну стільки разів, скільки захочемо. Ми побачимо кілька прикладів дуже скоро,
але спочатку дозволь мені згадати позначення, яке ми використовуємо для цієї множини — множини, породженої P1 через PR:
це P1 через PR, розділені комами всередині кутових дужок. Схоже, що ми можемо легко сплутати
це позначення з нотацією Дірака, але це зазвичай не відбувається, і це традиційне позначення в теорії
груп. Ось приклад множини, породженої X, Y і Z, тож N дорівнює одному в цьому прикладі, оскільки немає
тензорних добутків, і ми беремо всі три неодиничні матриці Паулі як генератори. Виявляється, що існує
16 матриць, які можна породити, формуючи добутки, що включають ці три матриці, і ти можеш вивести це
через правила множення, які ми бачили раніше. Зокрема, ми, звісно, можемо отримати X, Y і Z, а також одиничну матрицю,
і насправді ми також можемо отримати будь-яку з цих чотирьох матриць, помноженою на i, 1 або мінус i, — і це
WEBVTT
все. Ця множина широко відома як група Паулі. Ми також могли б розглянути множину,
породжену лише X і Z, і в цьому разі ми отримуємо половину групи Паулі.
І останній приклад, принаймні поки що: ми можемо розглянути множину, породжену X⊗X і Z⊗Z, тож N дорівнює
двом у цьому разі, і цього разу ми отримуємо лише чотири елементи, що зумовлено тим, що X⊗X і Z⊗Z
комутують одне з одним. Матриці Паулі та N-qubit-ові операції Паулі в загальному описують
унітарні операції, незалежно від того, є вони помилками чи навмисними. Але вони також описують
вимірювання. Точніше кажучи, починаючи лише з трьох неодиничних матриць Паулі, ми можемо пов'язати кожну з цих
матриць із проєктивним вимірюванням, визначеним через її власні значення та власні вектори. На екрані
ми маємо спектральні розкладання цих матриць, які допоможуть прояснити це. По суті, коли ми говоримо про вимірювання X,
вимірювання Y або вимірювання Z, ми маємо на увазі проєктивне вимірювання, визначене проєкціями
на власні підпростори цих матриць. Зазвичай ми вважаємо власні значення відповідними
результатами вимірювання. Наприклад, вимірювання X — це вимірювання у базисі плюс/мінус
qubit-а, або, альтернативно, ми можемо описати його множиною, що містить проєкції |+⟩⟨+| і
|−⟩⟨−|. Вимірювання Z, з іншого боку, — це не що інше, як стандартне базисне
вимірювання, хоча, як я вже сказав, ми іноді ототожнюємо власні значення з результатами вимірювання, і якщо ми це робимо,
то результати є плюс один і мінус один, а не 0 і 1 відповідно. Насправді ми можемо зробити щось
подібне для довільних ермітових матриць, і термін «спостережувана» зазвичай використовується в цій ситуації. Для матриць Паулі
та N-qubit-ових операцій Паулі в загальному ми можемо виконувати такі вимірювання неруйнівно за допомогою
фазової оцінки. І просто щоб переконатися, що ця схема зрозуміла: тут ми виконуємо вимірювання неруйнівно на
верхньому qubit-і, тоді як нижній qubit завжди ініціалізується у стан плюс, тобто застосуванням Hadamard до стану
нуль, бо саме так працює фазова оцінка. Зверни увагу, що оскільки власні значення
є просто плюс один і мінус один у цьому разі, нам потрібен лише один керуючий qubit, яким є нижній qubit у цій
схемі. Більше, ніж один, було б лише марнотратством, оскільки є лише один біт точності, про який слід турбуватися. Власне значення
є або плюс один, або мінус один, і вимірювання вже є ідеальним саме так. Результат цього вимірювання,
тобто стандартне базисне вимірювання в circuit-і, буде нуль для результату з власним значенням плюс один,
що відповідає стану плюс у разі спостережуваної X, а результат — один для власного значення мінус один
або стану мінус у цьому разі. Все, що я щойно сказав, природно поширюється на N-qubit-ові операції Паулі,
за умови, що ми пам'ятаємо: коли ми думаємо про спостережувану, ми говоримо про вимірювання власних значень,
а не вимірювання відносно базису власних векторів. Наприклад, розглянемо
двоqubit-ову операцію Паулі Z⊗Z: знову ж таки, є два власних значення — плюс один і мінус один, тому
вимірювання описується двома проєкціями. Зверни увагу зокрема, що вимірювання, яке ми пов'язуємо з
цією спостережуваною, — це не те саме, що вимірювання обох qubit-ів вимірюванням Z або, іншими словами, стандартним базисним вимірюванням, а радше двохрезультатне
проєктивне вимірювання, де проєкції — на простори, натягнуті всіма власними векторами, що відповідають
кожному з двох власних значень плюс один і мінус один. Інший спосіб думати про це: власні значення тензорного
добутку є добутками власних значень окремих матриць, тензорні добутки яких ми беремо, і
оскільки мінус 1 × мінус 1 дорівнює плюс 1 × плюс 1, наприклад, це вимірювання не
розрізняє |00⟩ та |11⟩. Тому якщо ми виміряємо, скажімо, стан Белла Φ⁺ цим вимірюванням,
описаним цією спостережуваною, ми неодмінно отримаємо результат, що відповідає власному значенню плюс один,
і стан залишиться незмінним, на відміну від колапсу до |00⟩ або |11⟩, що сталося б, якщо б ми
виконали стандартні базисні вимірювання на двох qubit-ах. Отже, вимірювання Z⊗Z — це не
те саме, що виконання двох Z-вимірювань незалежно, але насправді ми можемо виконувати такі вимірювання за допомогою фазової
оцінки точно так само, як і раніше, використовуючи один керуючий qubit, як показано на схемі circuit-а, що
узагальнюється на будь-яку N-qubit-ову операцію Паулі замість Z⊗Z. Коли ми маємо лише матриці Паулі Z,
між іншим, ми можемо спростити circuit ось так, і це розкриває — що також очевидно з проєкцій, що визначають
вимірювання, — що виконання вимірювання Z⊗Z на двох qubit-ах еквівалентне вимірюванню їхньої парності
в термінах стандартного базису, і це узагальнюється на тензорний добуток будь-якої кількості матриць Паулі Z.
Далі ми ще раз розглянемо трибітовий код повторення, цього разу формулюючи його в термінах операцій Паулі.
Це буде наш перший, досить простий приклад стабілізаторного коду, і ми обговоримо, як узагальнити це
поняття незабаром, але корисно спочатку побачити, як це працює у цьому простому випадку. Нагадаємо, що коли ми застосовуємо
трибітовий код повторення до qubit-ів, ми кодуємо заданий стан qubit-а α|0⟩+β|1⟩ як α|000⟩+β|111⟩,
і для зручності назвемо це трьохqubit-ове кодування ψ. Тому за визначенням ψ — це коректне тришubit-ове
кодування стану qubit-а, але якщо ми хочемо це перевірити, достатньо переконатися, що наступні два рівняння є істинними. Перше
рівняння стверджує, що застосування операцій Z до двох лівих qubit-ів ψ нічого не робить з ψ, тобто ψ
є власним вектором Z⊗Z⊗I, або просто ZZI скорочено, з власним значенням один. Друге
рівняння аналогічне, але операції Z застосовуються до двох правих qubit-ів. Ідея в тому, що якщо ми думаємо про ψ
як про лінійну комбінацію стандартних базисних станів, то перше рівняння означає, що ми можемо мати ненульові коефіцієнти лише для стандартних базисних станів,
де два лівих біти мають парну парність, або, еквівалентно, є рівними. Друге рівняння означає, що ми можемо мати
ненульові коефіцієнти лише для стандартних базисних станів, у яких два правих біти мають парну парність. Ще один спосіб думати про це —
розглядати ці дві операції Паулі як спостережувані, і якщо б ми виміряли ці дві спостережувані за допомогою
спрощеної схеми circuit-а, яку я щойно згадав, то ми неодмінно отримали б результат вимірювання, що відповідає власному значенню плюс один,
оскільки ψ є власним вектором обох спостережуваних з власним значенням один. Але ця спрощена версія об'єднаного
WEBVTT
circuit-а для незалежного вимірювання спостережуваних — це не що інше, як наш circuit перевірки парності для трибітового
коду повторення, і ми бачимо, що ці два рівняння разом еквівалентні тому, що circuit перевірки парності видає 00,
що є синдромом, який вказує на відсутність виявлених помилок. Тришubit-ові операції Паулі
ZZI та IZZ називаються генераторами стабілізатора для цього коду, а стабілізатор коду — це множина,
породжена генераторами стабілізатора. Ця множина — стабілізатор — є фундаментально важливим математичним
об'єктом, пов'язаним з цим кодом, і ми далі обговоримо роль, яку він відіграє, у міру просування уроку. Поки що
зауважу лише, що ми могли б зробити інший вибір генераторів — наприклад, замість одного з
вибраних нами генераторів ми могли б взяти ZIZ, і код і стабілізатор були б рівно такими самими. Далі ми розглянемо виявлення бітових перевертань
у трибітовому коді повторення з акцентом на взаємодіях і взаємозв'язках між операціями Паулі,
які задіяні, а саме — генераторами стабілізатора та самими помилками. Припустимо, що ми закодували
qubit за допомогою трибітового коду повторення, і бітове перевертання сталося на лівому qubit-і. Це призводить до того, що наш стан ψ
перетворюється відповідно до дії операції X, або помилки X, на лівому qubit-і. Як ми вже знаємо, ми можемо виявити
цю помилку, виконавши перевірки парності для трибітового коду повторення, або, еквівалентно, ми можемо виміряти
кодування неруйнівно, розглядаючи генератори стабілізатора як спостережувані. Почнімо з першого
генератора стабілізатора і подивимося, що відбувається. Наш стан зазнав впливу помилки X, і ми хочемо зрозуміти,
як вимірювання генератора стабілізатора як спостережуваної впливає на цю помилку. X і Z антикомутують,
тоді як все комутує з одиничною матрицею, і тому випливає, що ZZI антикомутує з XII,
тому ми отримуємо мінус-знак при зміні порядку. Ми також знаємо, що ZZI нічого не робить з ψ,
оскільки ψ є коректним кодуванням qubit-а, а коректні кодування завжди є власними векторами плюс один обох генераторів
стабілізатора. Це залишає нас з мінус XII, застосованим до ψ, і тому XII, застосований до
ψ, є власним вектором ZZI з власним значенням мінус один. Ми також можемо зробити щось подібне
з другим генератором стабілізатора, але цього разу помилка комутує з генератором стабілізатора, і тому наш
пошкоджений стан знову є власним вектором генератора стабілізатора, але цього разу власне значення є додатнім
один. Отже, наш пошкоджений стан є власним вектором обох генераторів стабілізатора, і те, яке власне значення є — плюс один чи
мінус один, — визначається тим, чи помилка комутує або антикомутує з кожним генератором стабілізатора. Для першого
помилка і генератор стабілізатора антикомутують, а для другого — вони комутують, і завжди буде одне або інше, оскільки будь-які дві
операції Паулі або комутують, або антикомутують. Тим часом сам стан ψ насправді не відіграє важливої
ролі тут, за винятком того факту, що генератори стабілізатора діють на цей стан тривіально. Тому коли ми думаємо про
виявлення помилок, нам справді не потрібно перейматися конкретним закодованим станом — все, що важливо, це чи помилка комутує або антикомутує
з кожним генератором стабілізатора. Тому складімо таблицю з одним рядком для кожного генератора стабілізатора
і одним стовпцем для кожної помилки. Тут я включив лише помилки, що відповідають одному бітовому перевертанню,
а також відсутність помилки взагалі, яка позначається тензорним добутком одиничної матриці сама з собою три рази. Ми могли б додати більше стовпців для інших помилок, якщо захочемо,
але поки що зосередимося лише на цих помилках. Запис у таблиці є або плюс один, або мінус один залежно від того,
чи комутує або антикомутує помилка з генератором стабілізатора. Тому для кожної помилки в таблиці ми можемо подивитися на
відповідний стовпець, щоб побачити, як ця помилка перетворить будь-яке задане кодування у власний вектор плюс один або мінус один
кожного генератора стабілізатора. Ці стовпці точно відповідають синдрому, який ми отримали б від
перевірок парності, еквівалентних неруйнівним вимірюванням генераторів стабілізатора як
спостережуваних. Звісно, записи в цій таблиці є плюс один і мінус один, а не нуль і один відповідно,
і якщо ти хочеш, ти можеш думати про синдроми як про відповідні бінарні рядки, а не стовпці плюс одиниць і мінус одиниць, але є
пряма відповідність. І просто щоб зробити зв'язок між синдромами та власними значеннями більш зрозумілим і прямим,
я буду називати ці вектори плюс одиниць і мінус одиниць синдромами, як і раніше. Синдроми розповідають нам
дещо про те, яка помилка сталася, і зокрема, якщо ми знаємо, що сталася одна з цих чотирьох можливих помилок,
синдром вказує нам, яка саме, і ми можемо виправити її, застосувавши помилку знову,
якщо захочемо. Далі я скажу ще трохи про синдроми, і зокрема ми більш детально розглянемо
їхні алгебраїчні аспекти. Наші кодування — це тришubit-ові стани, тому вони є одиничними векторами у
восьмивимірному комплексному векторному просторі, і те, що роблять чотири можливих синдроми, — це розбивання цього восьмивимірного простору
на чотири двовимірні підпростори, тобто вектори в будь-якому з цих підпросторів завжди дадуть нам однаковий
синдром. Детальніше: ця діаграма ілюструє, як восьмивимірний простір поділяється.
Кожен генератор стабілізатора розбиває простір на два підпростори рівної розмірності, а саме на простір власних векторів плюс один
та простір власних векторів мінус один. Наприклад, власні вектори плюс один ZZI — це лінійні комбінації
стандартних базисних станів, у яких два лівих біти мають парну парність, а власні вектори мінус один — це лінійні
комбінації стандартних базисних станів, у яких два лівих біти мають непарну парність. Ситуація аналогічна для
іншого генератора стабілізатора, за винятком того, що це два правих біти, а не два лівих. Тому ці чотири підпростори легко
описати в цьому разі через дуже простий код. Зокрема, підпростір,
що відповідає синдрому (плюс один, плюс один), — це простір, натягнутий |000⟩ і |111⟩, тобто простір коректних
кодувань, і він називається кодовим простором. В загальному простори натягнуті стандартними базисними станами,
показаними у відповідних клітинках, хоча побачити синдроми не завжди так легко. Синдроми
також розбивають усі тришubit-ові операції Паулі, що представляють можливі помилки Паулі, на чотири рівні колекції
залежно від того, який синдром ця помилка спричинить. Наприклад, будь-яка операція Паулі,
що комутує з обома генераторами стабілізатора, призводить до синдрому (плюс один, плюс один), і серед 64 можливих тришubit-ових
операцій Паулі рівно 16 належать до цієї категорії, включно з трьома, згаданими на екрані, і так само для інших трьох
WEBVTT
синдромів. Це не очевидно, але це правда, і ця базова властивість — що синдроми розбивають і простір станів,
у якому живуть кодування, і всі можливі помилки Паулі у просторі — на рівні частини — є тим, що
вірно в загальному для стабілізаторних кодів, які ми незабаром точно визначимо. Хоча це здебільшого лише відступ,
варто зазначити, що операції Паулі, які комутують з обома генераторами стабілізатора, або, еквівалентно,
операції Паулі, що призводять до синдрому (плюс один, плюс один), але самі не пропорційні елементам стабілізатора, поводяться точно як
однoqubit-ові операції Паулі на логічному qubit-і, який ми закодували. Наприклад, XXX комутує з
обома генераторами стабілізатора, але не пропорційний жодному елементу стабілізатора, і справді, якщо ти
подумаєш про цей код на мить, стане зрозуміло, що ефект, який ця операція має на кодування, еквівалентний gate-у X на
логічному qubit-і, який був закодований. І знову — це щось, що узагальнюється на всі стабілізаторні коди. Тепер час визначити стабілізаторні
коди в загальному, і це працює так: ми робимо щось цілком аналогічне тому, що ми щойно обговорили для
трибітового коду повторення, за винятком того, що ми вибираємо різні генератори стабілізатора, які я позначатиму P1
через PR для цього пояснення. Ці генератори стабілізатора мають бути всі N-qubit-овими операціями Паулі,
де N — кількість qubit-ів, що використовуються для кодування, і ми не можемо просто вибрати будь-який набір генераторів стабілізатора — вони
повинні задовольняти кілька основних умов. По-перше, всі генератори стабілізатора МАЮТЬ комутувати одне з
одним. У випадку трибітового коду повторення ми не потрудилися звернути на це увагу, але це легко спостерегти: ZZI і IZZ
справді комутують, оскільки Z комутує сам з собою і все комутує з
одиничною матрицею. Для стабілізаторних кодів зі складнішими генераторами стабілізатора, включно з кодами, де у нас є
і X, і Z у генераторах стабілізатора, це важлива умова, яку потрібно
перевірити. Один спосіб думати про необхідність цієї умови: ми збираємося розглядати генератори стабілізатора як спостережувані, і вимагаючи,
щоб вони всі комутували, ми гарантуємо, що порядок, у якому ми виконуємо ці вимірювання, не
має значення. По-друге, генератори стабілізатора мають утворювати так званий мінімальний породжуючий набір, що означає: якщо ми видалимо будь-який
один з них, ми отримаємо менший стабілізатор. Один спосіб висловити це математично показаний тут на
екрані. Строго кажучи, ця умова не є справді необхідною для функціонування стабілізаторного коду в операційному
сенсі, і іноді має сенс думати про немінімальні породжуючі набори, як ми побачимо на наступному уроці, але
для аналізу стабілізаторних кодів і пояснення їхніх властивостей ми будемо вважати, що ця умова
виконана. В основному ця умова гарантує, що кожна спостережувана, яку ми вимірюємо для отримання синдрому, додає
інформацію про можливі помилки, а не є надлишковою і не дає результатів, які можна легко вивести з інших генераторів стабілізатора як
спостережуваних. І нарешті, необхідно, щоб існував хоча б один ненульовий вектор, що фіксується всіма
генераторами стабілізатора, і це виявляється еквівалентним вимогам того, що мінус одиниця, помножена на одиничну матрицю на N qubit-ах, не
міститься в стабілізаторі. Це не очевидно, але суть в тому, що дійсно можна вибрати мінімальний породжуючий
набір N-qubit-ових операцій Паулі, що всі комутують одна з одною, але жоден вектор не є одночасно власним вектором плюс один
усіх них, і ми не хочемо займатися цією можливістю, оскільки коди, у яких немає жодних коректних кодувань, не є
цікавими. Отже, це вимоги до генераторів стабілізатора для стабілізаторного коду, і якщо ми маємо набір генераторів,
що задовольняє ці умови, то ми маємо коректний стабілізаторний код і можемо розглядати його властивості. Існує багато
різних стабілізаторних кодів з різними властивостями, що роблять їх цікавими чи ні, але всі вони задовольняють певні базові
властивості, що нагадують ті, які ми вже спостерігали для трибітового коду повторення.
Незабаром ми розглянемо кілька прикладів, але перед цим дозволь мені зазначити, що коли ми говоримо про кодовий простір стабілізаторного коду, ми маємо на увазі підпростір
N-qubit-ового простору станів, що включає кожен вектор, який є одночасно власним вектором плюс один кожного з
генераторів стабілізатора. Це підпростір N-qubit-ового простору станів, у якому живуть коректні кодування, і ми скажемо більше про
цей підпростір у міру просування уроку. Тепер давай розглянемо кілька прикладів стабілізаторних
кодів. Ось приклад, який ми вже обговорили: звичайний трибітовий код повторення. Ми також можемо виразити
модифіковану версію цього коду з попереднього уроку, яка може виявляти фазове перевертання замість бітового перевертання, як стабілізаторний код, як показано
тут. Цього разу генератори стабілізатора вимірюють спостережувані XX, а не ZZ, тому це в основному
перевірки парності у базисі плюс/мінус, а не у стандартному базисі. В обох випадках ми можемо
одразу побачити, що ми маємо коректний стабілізаторний код, оскільки генератори стабілізатора комутують. Це мінімальні
породжуючі набори, і кодовий простір є нетривіальним, як ми вже знаємо. Але ми також досить ясно бачимо, що ми
не можемо породити мінус одиницю, помножену на одиничну матрицю. Ось дев'ятиqubit-овий код Шора, який також є стабілізаторним кодом,
виражений через генератори стабілізатора. В цьому разі у нас в основному є три копії трибітового
коду повторення — по одній для кожного з трьох блоків по три qubit-и, — а також два останніх генератори стабілізатора, які
мають вигляд, що нагадує circuit, який ми бачили на попередньому уроці для виявлення фазових перевертань у цьому
коді. Інший спосіб думати про ці два останніх генератори стабілізатора — це те, що вони мають точно таку саму форму, як ми
маємо для трибітового коду повторення для фазових перевертань, за винятком того, що ми підставляємо XXX замість X, і причина в тому,
що XXX відповідає операції X на логічному qubit-і, закодованому за допомогою трибітового коду повторення, але
це відступ, і про це зараз не варто турбуватися. На випадок, якщо це не зрозуміло, далі ми розглянемо ще кілька
прикладів, але перед цим дозволь мені зазначити, що люди часто опускають символи тензорного добутку при описі стабілізаторних кодів, оскільки це, як правило,
робить їх легшими для читання. Ось як виглядають ці коди без символів тензорного добутку:
але звісно, це тензорні добутки, а не звичайні добутки матриць — наприклад, ми просто опускаємо символи тензорного добутку, щоб було менше
захаращеності і закономірності були більш чіткими. Ось ще один приклад — він називається
семиqubit-овим кодом Стіна, і він має досить визначні особливості. Ми повернемося до нього
ще не раз протягом решти уроків розділу, але зараз ми можемо просто перевірити, що це дійсно коректний стабілізаторний
код. Зокрема, перші три генератори стабілізатора явно комутують одне з одним, оскільки Z комутує з
WEBVTT
собою, а одинична матриця комутує з усім, і ситуація аналогічна для останніх трьох. Тому залишається
перевірити, що якщо ми беремо один із Z-генераторів стабілізатора і один із X-генераторів стабілізатора, то вони комутують,
і досить легко перебрати дев'ять можливих пар, щоб перевірити, що в усіх цих випадках ми завжди
будемо мати X і Z, що збігаються в одній позиції парну кількість разів, тому два генератори комутуватимуть, так само як
XX і ZZ комутують. Це мінімальний породжуючий набір із нетривіальним кодовим простором, але
я не буду намагатися доводити це у цьому відео, а натомість залишу це тобі для роздумів, якщо захочеш. Семиqubit-овий код Стіна схожий
на дев'ятиqubit-овий код Шора в тому сенсі, що він кодує один qubit і дозволяє виправляти довільну помилку на одному qubit-і, але потребує лише
семи qubit-ів, а не дев'яти. Це не найменша кількість qubit-ів, необхідна для коригуючого коду, щоб
закодувати qubit і виправити довільну помилку на одному qubit-і. Ось стабілізаторний код, який зазвичай
називають просто п'ятиqubit-овим кодом, він також кодує один qubit і може виправити довільну однoqubit-ову помилку,
і п'ять — це найменша кількість qubit-ів, для якої це можливо. Ось ще один приклад
стабілізаторного коду, хоча це насправді не код у строгому сенсі, оскільки кодовий простір є
одновимірним. Зокрема, кодовий простір цього коду — це простір, натягнутий ebit-ом, або іншими словами стан Белла Φ⁺,
тому ти насправді не можеш кодувати жодних qubit-ів за допомогою цього коду, але це все одно є коректним стабілізаторним кодом, де кодовий
простір є одновимірним, і щось подібне можна зробити для стану GHZ.
Отже, ось кілька прикладів стабілізаторних кодів, і ми побачимо нескінченно більше прикладів на
наступному уроці. Припустимо, що нам дано стабілізаторний код — природне питання, яке виникає щодо нього
— мабуть, перше питання, що спадає на думку, — скільки qubit-ів він кодує? Це питання має дуже просту
відповідь, і щоб пояснити її, давай точно визначимо розглядуваний стабілізаторний код. Ми маємо R N-qubit-ових
генераторів стабілізатора P1 через PR, що задовольняють три вимоги, які я згадував раніше, а саме: генератори
стабілізатора всі комутують одне з одним, це мінімальний породжуючий набір, тому ми не отримали б той самий
стабілізатор, видаливши один з генераторів, і існує хоча б один ненульовий вектор у кодовому
просторі. Як свідчить теорема, показана на екрані, тоді кодовий простір стабілізаторного коду повинен мати
розмірність 2^(N−R), або інакше кажучи, ми можемо закодувати N
мінус R qubit-ів за допомогою цього коду. Інтуїтивно кажучи, у нас є N qubit-ів у кодуваннях, і кожен
генератор стабілізатора фактично забирає один qubit з погляду того, скільки qubit-ів ми можемо закодувати.
Цю теорему не надто важко довести, і я покажу тобі доведення за мить, але спочатку ми розглянемо лише
кілька прикладів. Починаючи зі звичайного трибітового коду повторення, ми маємо три qubit-и у
кодуваннях, тобто N дорівнює трьом, і є R = 2 генератори стабілізатора, тому ми можемо закодувати один
qubit за допомогою цього коду. Зауваж, що це не стосується того, які або скільки помилок можна виявити або
виправити — це інше питання. Це лише твердження про розмірність кодового
простору. Ще один приклад: розглянемо п'ятиqubit-овий код. Тут у нас є п'ять qubit-ів і чотири
генератори стабілізатора, тому знову кодовий простір має розмірність два, що означає, що ми можемо закодувати один qubit за допомогою цього
коду. І ще один приклад поки що: для стабілізаторного коду ebit-а у нас два qubit-и і два генератори стабілізатора, тому
кодовий простір є одновимірним, і, як я вже згадував, це простір, натягнутий станом Белла Φ⁺.
Ми побачимо більше прикладів у міру просування, включно з кодами, де ми можемо кодувати більше одного qubit-а, але зараз давай
подивимося, як ми можемо довести теорему. Перше, що нам потрібно спостерегти: оскільки генератори
стабілізатора комутують і утворюють мінімальний породжуючий набір, і оскільки кожна операція Паулі є власним оберненим елементом, кожен
елемент у стабілізаторі може бути виражений єдиним способом як добуток, де ми зводимо кожен генератор стабілізатора
PK у степінь AK, де кожен AK є або нулем, або одиницею, а потім множимо результати
разом. Інакше кажучи, ми отримуємо кожен елемент стабілізатора, перемножуючи деяку підмножину
генераторів стабілізатора, і ніколи не отримуємо той самий елемент стабілізатора з різних підмножин. Одне, що
з цього випливає: єдиний спосіб виразити N-qubit-ову тотожну операцію таким чином — взяти всі степені рівними
нулю. Далі визначимо πK як проєкцію на власний підпростір плюс один від PK для кожного K від 1 до R. Є
проста формула для цієї проєкції: ми можемо просто усереднити PK з одиничною матрицею на N qubit-ах, що фактично залишає
власні значення плюс один незмінними і зсуває всі власні значення мінус один до нуля. Тепер кодовий простір визначено як множину всіх векторів, що є одночасно власними векторами плюс один всіх
генераторів стабілізатора. Оскільки генератори стабілізатора комутують, проєкції також мають комутувати, і це
означає, що добуток цих проєкцій також є проєкцією, і зокрема це проєкція на
перетин підпросторів, на які проєктують окремі проєкції, або іншими словами це проєкція на
кодовий простір. Ми можемо розкрити цей добуток, і отримаємо середнє по всіх
елементах стабілізатора. І нарешті, оскільки розмірність будь-якого підпростору дорівнює
сліду проєкції на цей підпростір, ми знаходимо, що розмірність кодового простору — це середнє слідів по елементах
стабілізатора. Але за винятком N-qubit-ової тотожної операції всі елементи стабілізатора мають
слід, що дорівнює нулю, оскільки три неодиничних матриці Паулі всі мають слід, що дорівнює нулю. Слід N-qubit-ової тотожної
операції дорівнює 2^N, і тому ми знаходимо, що розмірність кодового простору дорівнює 2^(N−R), що доводить
теорему. Далі я скажу зовсім небагато про те, як qubit-и можна кодувати за допомогою стабілізаторних кодів, але для цього нам спочатку
потрібно ввести операції Кліффорда. Операції Кліффорда — це унітарні операції на будь-якій кількості
qubit-ів, які можна реалізувати за допомогою квантових circuit-ів з обмеженим набором gate-ів, а саме gate-ів Hadamard, gate-ів S
та gate-ів CNOT. Зверни увагу, що gate-и T не включені, як і gate-и Тоффолі або Фредкіна,
і не тільки ці gate-и не включені до цього списку, але насправді неможливо реалізувати ці gate-и
за допомогою тих, що перелічені тут, тому вони не є операціями Кліффорда. Операції Паулі, з іншого
WEBVTT
боку, є операціями Кліффорда, і зокрема їх можна реалізувати за допомогою послідовностей gate-ів Hadamard і S.
Отже, це простий спосіб визначити операції Кліффорда, але він насправді не пояснює, чому вони визначені саме так
або що особливого в цій конкретній колекції gate-ів. Ось реальна причина, чому операції Кліффорда визначені саме так:
з точністю до глобальної фази N-qubit-ові операції Кліффорда — це точно унітарні
операції, що завжди перетворюють операції Паулі в операції Паулі шляхом спряження. Точніше кажучи, N-qubit-ова
унітарна операція U є операцією Кліффорда з точністю до глобального фазового множника тоді і тільки тоді, коли для кожної N-qubit-ової операції Паулі
спряження цієї операції Паулі з U дає нам плюс або мінус один, помножений на деяку (можливо, іншу) N-qubit-ову
операцію Паулі. Ти легко можеш перевірити, що ця властивість є істинною для gate-ів Hadamard, gate-ів S
та gate-ів CNOT, тому вона обов'язково виконується для circuit-ів, побудованих з цих gate-ів. Складніше довести, що це
йде в зворотньому напрямку, тобто якщо нам дано конкретну N-qubit-ову унітарну операцію U, що задовольняє цю
властивість, то її обов'язково можна реалізувати з точністю до глобальної фази лише за допомогою gate-ів Hadamard, S і CNOT.
Я не буду доводити це твердження, але воно є істинним, і ти можеш знайти його,
якщо тебе це цікавить. Операції Кліффорда не є універсальними для квантових обчислень, тобто ми не можемо виконувати довільні
квантові обчислення, використовуючи лише gate-и Hadamard, S і CNOT. Насправді для заданого значення N існує лише скінченна кількість
N-qubit-ових операцій Кліффорда, тобто це дискретна множина операцій. Тому, на відміну від
універсального набору квантових gate-ів, ми не можемо апроксимувати довільні унітарні операції до будь-якого бажаного рівня точності. І
насправді виконання операцій Кліффорда на стандартних базисних станах із подальшими стандартними базисними вимірюваннями не дозволяє нам
виконувати обчислення, що виходять за межі можливостей класичних алгоритмів, оскільки ми можемо ефективно симулювати обчислення такого роду
класично. Цей факт відомий як теорема Готтесмана–Кніла, і стандартне доведення цієї теореми певним чином
ґрунтується на формалізмі стабілізаторів. Зокрема, це працює так: ми можемо відстежувати, як операції Кліффорда перетворюють операції
Паулі шляхом спряження — це можна зробити ефективно, — а потім виводити з цього, що роблять
обчислення з qubit-ами. Отже, яке це має відношення до стабілізаторних кодів? Стабілізаторний код надає нам
кодовий простір певної розмірності, і ми маємо свободу використовувати цей кодовий простір як завгодно. Тому ніщо не змушує нас кодувати
qubit-и в цей простір певним чином, але завжди буде можливо виконати кодування за допомогою операції Кліффорда
як кодувальника. Це зручно, оскільки операції Кліффорда відносно прості порівняно з довільними унітарними
операціями. Існують способи оптимізувати їхню реалізацію, що діють за принципом, схожим на доведення теореми Готтесмана–
Кніла, і в результаті circuit-и для їхньої реалізації ніколи не повинні бути надто
великими. Зокрема, ми завжди можемо виконати кодування за допомогою операції Кліффорда, що потребує дещо менше квадратичного числа gate-ів,
оскільки це насправді є правдою для кожної операції Кліффорда. Тому підсумок такий: для заданого стабілізаторного коду завжди
можна ефективно кодувати qubit-и за допомогою цього коду, і математичні інструменти, корисні для розуміння операцій Кліффорда, можуть допомогти з цим
процесом. Наприклад, ось кодувальник для семиqubit-ового коду Стіна — це операція Кліффорда, і виявляється,
що цей не потребує навіть gate-ів S. Для загальних стабілізаторних кодів виявлення помилок працює таким
чином: як і раніше, ми припускаємо, що у нас є N-qubit-ові генератори стабілізатора P1 через PR, і нехай E буде N-qubit-овою операцією Паулі,
що представляє гіпотетичну помилку на кодуванні. Ми розглядаємо лише операції Паулі як помилки,
між іншим, оскільки дискретизація помилок працює так само для довільних стабілізаторних кодів, як і для дев'ятиqubit-ового коду Шора.
Спосіб перевірки на наявність помилок — вимірювати кожен із генераторів стабілізатора як
спостережувану. Є R генераторів стабілізатора, тому це означає R результатів, кожен з яких є плюс один або мінус
один, або бінарне значення, якщо ти хочеш пов'язати нуль із плюс один і один із мінус один. Ці R результатів
разом утворюють синдром — так само, як у трибітовому коді повторення, де R дорівнювало
двом. В загальному є три можливих випадки для помилки E з точки зору її виявлення, і вони такі. Перший:
може бути, що E знаходиться в стабілізаторі, тобто E можна породити з генераторів стабілізатора, або
дещо більш загально — E може бути еквівалентним елементу стабілізатора з точністю до глобальної
фази. В цьому разі E насправді взагалі не є помилкою, оскільки вона не має жодного ефекту в кодовому просторі, окрім можливого
введення глобальної фази, яка не має жодного ефекту. Тому нам взагалі не потрібно турбуватися про такі помилки. Яку б
нетривіальну дію вона не мала, вона відбувається поза кодовим простором, тому нас
це не стосується. Набагато більше занепокоєння викликає можливість того, що E не знаходиться в стабілізаторі навіть з точністю до глобальної фази, але
тим не менш вона комутує з кожним із наших генераторів стабілізатора. Пам'ятай, що саме
антикомутація помилки з генератором стабілізатора призводить до появи мінус один десь у синдромі,
але в цьому разі цього не відбувається. Тому це помилка, яка насправді змінює вектори в кодовому просторі певним
нетривіальним чином, і ми це знаємо, оскільки інакше вона була б пропорційна елементу стабілізатора, але вона
залишається невиявленою кодом. Отже, це поганий випадок: ми маємо помилку, яка потенційно змінює
будь-яку квантову інформацію, яку ми закодували, але код не знає про цей факт. Наприклад, для трибітового
коду повторення XXX потрапляє в цю категорію. І остання можливість — це те, що E
антикомутує принаймні з одним із генераторів стабілізатора, і це означає, що код виявляє цю помилку, оскільки
ми отримаємо синдром принаймні з одним мінус один десь у ньому, що вказує на те, що щось не так, і нам потрібно спробувати виправити цю помилку
якимось чином. Отже, це можливості. Як термінологічне зауваження:
коли ми говоримо про відстань стабілізаторного коду, ми маємо на увазі мінімальну вагу операції Паулі, що потрапляє
в другу категорію, тобто вона змінює кодовий простір певним нетривіальним чином, але код не
виявляє цього. І коли ми кажемо, що стабілізаторний код є [[N,M,D]]-стабілізаторним кодом,
використовуючи подвійні квадратні дужки, як показано на екрані, це означає, що кодування мають довжину N qubit-ів,
код здатний кодувати M qubit-ів, тобто кодовий простір має розмірність 2^M, а відстань дорівнює D. Тому помилка повинна мати
WEBVTT
вагу D або більше, щоб змінити логічний стан будь-якого qubit-а, який ми закодували, залишаючись невиявленою як
помилка. Тепер ми розглянемо семиqubit-овий код Стіна як приклад і визначимо, якою є його відстань.
Ось генератори стабілізатора для цього коду, і нагадаємо, що відстань — це мінімальна вага
N-qubit-ової операції Паулі, що комутує з усіма генераторами стабілізатора, але сама не знаходиться в стабілізаторі і
не пропорційна елементу стабілізатора. Ми визначимо, що цей код має відстань
три. Спосіб, яким ми це визначимо, — спочатку розглянути будь-яку операцію Паулі ваги не більше двох і
зробити висновок, що єдиний спосіб, яким вона може комутувати з усіма шістьма генераторами стабілізатора, — це бути тотожньою, яка завжди є елементом
стабілізатора. Тому припустимо, що можливо неодиничні матриці Паулі, що утворюють цю операцію (назвемо їх
P і Q), з'являються в двох крайніх лівих позиціях. Це лише один випадок, і нам справді потрібно
розглянути всі інші можливі місцезнаходження для цих можливо неодиничних матриць Паулі, але аргументація в основному однакова для всіх
можливих місцезнаходжень. Ну, за припущенням ця операція комутує з усіма шістьма
генераторами стабілізатора, тому зокрема вона комутує з цим одним і також комутує з цим.
Q збігається з одиничною матрицею в обох цих генераторах — ось чому ми їх і вибрали, — і у нас є одиничні
матриці в п'яти крайніх правих позиціях цієї помилки. Тому ми робимо висновок, що P має комутувати і з X,
і з Z, оскільки інакше ця помилка антикомутувала б з одним із цих двох генераторів. Але єдина матриця Паулі, що
комутує і з X, і з Z, — це тотожня, тому P має бути тотожньою. І тепер, коли ми це знаємо, ми можемо
вибрати ще два генератори стабілізатора, що мають X і Z у другій позиції зліва, і можемо
зробити аналогічний висновок про Q. Тому немає способу, щоб помилка ваги не більше двох залишилася невиявленою цим кодом,
якщо вона не є просто тотожньою операцією, яка знаходиться в стабілізаторі. Тому це насправді не є
помилкою. З іншого боку, існують операції Паулі ваги три, що комутують з усіма шістьма цими генераторами стабілізатора,
але не пропорційні елементам стабілізатора, і ось два приклади. Тому ми дійшли висновку, що цей
код має відстань три. Остання річ, яку ми обговоримо на цьому уроці, — це виправлення помилок для
стабілізаторних кодів. Як завжди, ми припускаємо, що наш код визначається N-qubit-овими генераторами стабілізатора
P1 через PR. Почнімо з роздумів про всі можливі помилки, які можуть
статися. Є 2^R можливих синдромів, і, як я вже згадував раніше на уроці, ці синдроми розбивають усі
можливі N-qubit-ові операції Паулі на рівні колекції, тому це означає 4^N / 2^R операцій Паулі
у кожній множині. Тому коли ми бачимо певний синдром, може бути, що будь-яка одна з цих 4^N, поділених на 2
до R, помилок є відповідальною. Ми трохи перераховуємо тут, хоча, оскільки деякі з цих
помилок мають точно однаковий ефект у кодовому просторі. Зокрема, якщо у нас є помилка E і ми множимо E на будь-який
елемент стабілізатора S, то ми отримаємо іншу помилку, що має точно такий самий ефект у кодовому просторі, що й E. Тому
це еквівалентні помилки. Стабілізатор має 2^R елементів, і якщо ми це врахуємо, то знайдемо,
що для кожного синдрому є 4^(N−R) класів еквівалентності помилок, які могли спричинити цей
синдром. І це означає, що якщо R не дорівнює N — у цьому разі у нас одновимірний кодовий простір і
тому ми не можемо закодувати жодних qubit-ів взагалі, — то неможливо виправити кожну помилку, яку ми можемо виявити. Натомість
ми маємо вибрати лише одну операцію виправлення для кожного синдрому в надії виправити лише один клас еквівалентних
помилок. Отже, як нам вирішити, яке виправлення виконати для кожного синдрому? Природна стратегія —
вибрати операцію Паулі найменшої ваги, що спричиняє будь-який синдром, який ми вимірюємо, з ідеєю, що операції Паулі меншої ваги
представляють більш імовірні пояснення для цього синдрому. Це може насправді і не бути
правдою для деяких моделей шуму, і ще одна природна стратегія — якимось чином обчислити найбільш імовірну помилку, що спричиняє
заданий синдром. Але поки що ми просто розглянемо стратегію, де ми намагаємось виправити помилки, вибираючи операцію Паулі найменшої ваги, що спричиняє
синдром. Для стабілізаторного коду з відстанню D ця стратегія завжди дозволяє нам виправляти помилки, що мають вагу строго
менше половини D, або іншими словами вагу не більше ⌊(D−1)/2⌋, і я коротко поясню, чому це
так. Це покаже, зокрема, що семиqubit-овий код Стіна може виправити будь-яку однocubit-ову помилку Паулі, і завдяки
дискретизації помилок це означає, що так само як дев'ятиqubit-овий код Шора, код Стіна може виправити довільну
помилку на одному qubit-і. Отже, ось як це працює. Уяви, що це коло представляє всі можливі операції Паулі,
що призводять до синдрому, що складається з усіх плюс один, — синдрому, який вказує на те, що помилок не відбулося
і все гаразд. Серед цих операцій у нас є елементи стабілізатора, або насправді
операції, пропорційні елементам стабілізатора, і ми також маємо нетривіальні помилки, що якимось чином змінюють кодовий простір, але не
виявляються кодом. За визначенням відстані ми знаємо, що кожна операція Паулі в цій категорії повинна мати вагу не менше
D, оскільки D визначається як мінімальна вага цих операцій. Ми також маємо операції Паулі,
що спричиняють появу інших синдромів, і ми могли б розглядати кожен синдром по черзі, якщо захочемо, але тут ми просто уявляємо,
що з'явився один такий синдром S. Тепер уяви, що E — це помилка в цій
категорії, що має вагу строго менше половини відстані D. Ну, ми не знаємо, що це
обов'язково є операцією мінімальної ваги в цьому колі, тому нехай C буде операцією мінімальної ваги в цій множині або однією з них у разі рівності,
тому може бути, що C дорівнює E, або, можливо, ні. Але оскільки C має
мінімальну вагу, ми знаємо, що вона не може мати вагу більшу, ніж вага E, оскільки C також знаходиться в множині
і має мінімальну вагу. Тому операція виправлення C повинна мати вагу строго менше половини
D. Отже, що відбудеться, якщо ми застосуємо це виправлення C до будь-якого нашого стану після помилки E?
Відповідь: стан, який ми отримаємо, — це C × E, помножене на вихідне кодування, оскільки ми спочатку
множимо на E — це була помилка — а потім множимо на C, щоб спробувати виправити її. І цей добуток повинен знаходитися в
стабілізаторі або бути пропорційним елементу стабілізатора. Ось чому: по-перше, оскільки E і C дають нам той самий
WEBVTT
синдром, C × E повинно давати синдром, що складається з усіх плюс один. Це тому, що для заданого
генератора стабілізатора або C і E обидва комутують з цим генератором, або вони обидва антикомутують — воно повинно бути однаковим для
обох, оскільки синдроми однакові. І якщо ти подумаєш про це на мить, це означає, що C × E повинно
комутувати з усіма генераторами стабілізатора. І нарешті, C × E повинно
знаходитися в стабілізаторі, оскільки його вага не може бути більшою за суму ваг C і E, і тому його вага
є строго меншою за D. Це означає, що ми успішно виправляємо E, оскільки застосування E, а потім C нічого не робить з
кодовим простором. Отже, це чудово, але є лише одна проблема, а саме: для стабілізаторних
кодів в загальному обчислення операції найменшої ваги, що спричиняє даний синдром, є обчислювально складною задачею,
і це насправді є правдою навіть для класичних кодів, які в цьому контексті ми можемо розглядати як стабілізаторні коди,
де всередині генераторів стабілізатора як тензорні множники з'являються лише одиничні матриці та матриці Паулі Z.
Тому, на відміну від кроку кодування, операції Кліффорда цього разу не приходять нам на допомогу, і єдине розумне
рішення — вибирати конкретні коди, для яких хороші виправлення можна обчислити ефективно, і для цього немає рецепту.
Простіше кажучи, розробка стабілізаторних кодів такого роду є частиною мистецтва
квантового проєктування кодів. І це гарне місце для завершення уроку. Сподіваюся, ти приєднаєшся до мене
на наступному уроці, в якому ми розглянемо деякі конкретні конструкції квантових кодів, включно з кодами, що ілюструють мистецтво квантового проєктування кодів
досить видатним чином. До побачення!